-Well, my new poll numbers are
in, and it's not looking good.
There's only one thing
left to do --
make cold calls
to normal, everyday Americans
and try to win back
their support.
[ Line ringing ]
Congratulations,
you're speaking to Donald Trump.
I'm calling undecided voters
who are way less rich
and way less successful than me.
What poor loser
am I speaking to?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Mike Bloomberg.
-Wait a second.
The Michael Bloomberg of
Bloomberg News and Bloomberg TV?
-That's right.
-And "Bloomberg Med"
and "Chicago Bloomberg"
and "Bloomberg 3: Tokyo Drift"?
-Sure, Donald.
-Well, this is fantastic.
I was gonna ask you
for your vote,
but now that I have you
on the phone,
how about I just ask you some
questions like an interview?
Even a stable genius like me
would like to pick
Mike Bloomberg's very smart,
very huge brain.
-You know I'm running
against you, right?
-Like I said -- very dumb brain.
It's a teeny-tiny,
very small brain.
Okay, let's get started --
Why exactly are you running
for president?
-Well, I've joined the race
to return our country to sanity
and honesty...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...so we can be proud
of America again,
and step one is giving you
a New York goodbye.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa.
What's a New York goodbye?
-Sending you back to Queens
in a Yellow Cab
while Times Square Elmo
flips you off.
[ Laughter,
cheers and applause ]
-Wow. That's very mean, Mike.
Very mean. Very nasty.
Very nasty. Very nasty answer.
Didn't expect that from you.
Very, very nasty.
Next question --
What makes you think
you'd be a better president
than me?
And you can't cheat
and use facts.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, let's see --
I'm a self-made businessman,
a proven leader,
and a New York icon,
whereas you just play
those things on TV.
[ Laughter,
cheers and applause ]
Plus, I was mayor
of the greatest city in America
with the greatest audience
in the world.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well, I do love
New York City mayors.
I even keep one as a pet.
Good boy.
Good boy. Good boy.
But, anyway, this is
the big leagues, Mike,
the bigly big leagues,
so let me ask --
What would you do if you got
to sit where I'm sitting?
-Well, first, I'd wipe
the KFC grease off the seat...
[ Laughter ]
...maybe take some of those
Kid Rock posters off the walls,
and then I'd tackle key issues
like climate change
and gun safety
and income inequality...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...which would mean
raising taxes on billionaires.
-Wait. I'm gonna have to pay
more in taxes?
-No, I said billionaires.
[ Laughter,
cheers and applause ]
-That was a low blow, Mike.
I'm actually a very successful
person just like you.
I've created and run
many beautiful businesses,
and none of them have failed...
besides the casinos.
-And the university?
-Oh, yeah.
-And the magazine.
-That's right.
-And the steaks.
-Uh-huh.
-And the water.
-Forgot about that one.
-And the board game.
-I did that?
-And the vodka.
-Pour one out.
-And the airline.
-Okay! Okay! Okay!
Let's change the subject!
I don't like this.
I don't like this game.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Here's one more very perfect,
very important question --
Are you watching the Super Bowl
this weekend?
-Yes, I am. Actually,
I have a 60-second commercial
airing during the game.
-Really? Me, too.
What's yours about?
-It's about an important issue
facing our country right now
and how I can use my experience
as a mayor and business leader
to bring America forward.
-Cool.
In my commercial, I get really
angry, then I eat a Snickers bar
and turn into Betty White.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, it's been a fun
interview, "Mini" Mike.
That's my nickname for you,
by the way, Mini Mike.
Do you have
any nicknames for me?
-Well, usually,
I just call you that [bleep].
[ Laughter ]
-Whoa! Whoa! Whoa! Stop that!
I've heard enough.
I guess you learn a lot of
colorful words in New York City.
Rudy! No! Rudy!
I got to go, Mike.
Rudy just peed on the carpet.
No, Rudy! Bad boy! Rudy!